[Music]
one of the questions I get asked most
commonly as an astronomer is if almost
all the galaxies in the universe are
flying away from us in space why is the
Andromeda galaxy getting closer to us
does that somehow mean that the Big Bang
works differently in different parts of
the universe
and the answer simply is no space is
expanding because of the Big Bang all of
space is expanding in every direction
all at once and from our viewpoint that
means that it looks like all the other
galaxies are moving away from us but not
all the universe around us appears to be
expanding for example the earth doesn't
seem to be getting any farther away from
the Sun the Sun is not getting any
farther away from our galaxy think about
smaller scales like your body your body
luckily is not expanding along with the
universe and the reason is that the
expansion of the universe is actually a
pretty gentle force you really only
notice it our in the middle of nowhere
in the vast reaches of space between the
galaxies there's a lot of space out
there so there's a lot of space to
expand and so you really notice this
expansion but there are things that are
stronger than the expansion force for
example my body is held together by
chemical forces and by electrical forces
that is much much stronger than the tiny
little push the space has to expand
inside me I hold together very well one
of the analogies I think about is you
could try to push over the Empire State
Building by blowing on it
you are actually exerting a force on the
Empire State Building by blowing on it
you can measure that force but you're
not gonna blow over the Empire State
Building there are things that are much
stronger than this omnipresent but
gentle force of the expansion of the
universe the gravity between the Sun and
the earth is stronger then spaces
pressure to expand over that scale
that's also true of the galaxy we are
held in orbit around the center of the
galaxy gravitationally that's much
stronger than any expansion force so why
isn't dromeda different Andromeda is
close enough to our Milky Way galaxy
that the gravity between
the two is strong enough for the two to
start moving together yes space is
expanding between us and the Andromeda
galaxy but gravity is accelerating
Andromeda toward us faster than that
expansion and in fact that means that
Andromeda is going to collide with the
Milky Way in a couple billion years and
we see this happening all over the
universe there are clusters of galaxies
where the galaxies are close enough
together that they are merging and
colliding when galaxies are far enough
away from each other that the
gravitational force is weaker and the
acceleration due to gravity is weaker
than the outward expansion then they
start moving away now one of the
intriguing things is that we don't know
what the future holds when it comes to
the expansion force of the universe just
recently in the last couple of decades
we've measured that the universe is not
only expanding but it's actually
accelerating in some ways that force is
getting stronger and stronger all the
time and we don't know whether that will
stop or whether that will stay constant
or whether in fact that expansion force
will keep getting stronger will there be
a day when the expansion force of the
universe is strong enough that our
galaxy does start to expand and the
Stars start to move farther and farther
away from each other
will there come a time when the Sun and
the earth are actually pulled apart by
the expansion of the universe and
perhaps most intriguingly
will there ever come a time when the
expansion of the universe is strong them
to rip apart your atoms to actually have
matter disappear into a little soup of
organic particles we call this idea the
big rip and it's one of the possible
ends of the universe that the expansion
force will eventually get so strong it
literally rips everything apart we don't
know whether this will happen yet so we
have a lot more investigating to do
about this thing called dark energy that
may be accelerating the universe and
that's one of the best questions are
trying to answer right now
[Music]